do we have a lot of screenwriters in
their 20s that watch our videos and
they're just starting out and they're in
an early stage of their writing careers
is there any advice you can give to them
oh sure luck no one I think one of the
best tips is it was I I heard a female
showrunner say when she came out to LA
she spent the first year reading every
single pilot that had been picked up
that she could get her hands on and that
could and also maybe reading pilots of
series from a couple years ago
I do feel that's when I said like
Shakespeare for me was one of my best
teachers just understanding how
well-defined his characters were the
dialogue and the conflicts and they you
know the characters needs and wants and
what gets in their way and I mean it the
stakes you don't get bigger than
Shakespeare with Macbeth or Hamlet and
so there are great teachers and great
like Matthew one or we you can watch Mad
Men absolutely you know you can watch a
lot of series but there is something
about seeing the written word the other
thing as an exercise and I think this is
a very powerful exercise it might not
seem like fun but it can be fun is to
watch if you're I did this actually when
I was in my 20s starting out officer and
a gentleman and this is before you could
download scripts on the internet I did I
watched the whole movie and I wrote down
as I was watching it what each scene was
so I had to pause a lot but it what it
does is it really helps you understand
and get a feel for rhythm and structure
almost through osmosis through that
process of doing it and the point of
doing it isn't so you can go and you're
not plagiarizing or copying it's to get
you to just understand
and rhythms of scenes and how they flow
from one to the next and what and you
you can see when you're doing it okay
whereas what's the Act one the Act one
break usually it's supposed to be around
page 27 in the feature so you see where
that kind of flows when you're copying
you know a script and if you don't have
to do every single line baby okay
Richard Richard Gere's with his father
they wake up right after they've had an
evening of debauchery and hookers and
Richard Gere is now off to to training
camp in the military then the next scene
and I don't remember exactly but let's
say the next scene is he's on a bus and
we see exterior there the facility then
next scene maybe we see Debra Winger as
a waitress I don't remember everything
so forgive me but it also gets you into
the understanding and the that
screenwriter is a wonderful screenwriter
the it gets you into seeing how when I
was talking about not including the dull
bits you can see beautiful
juxtapositions like he's off to the
military and then maybe the next thing
he's in line and being asked to salute
and it's just it's a wonderful exercise
that this woman who has became a
successful writer in television she read
pilot so if you feel like you're want to
be a half-hour person and if you want to
do multicam and you feel like NBC CBS
ABC style sit comes or your thing which
are multicam versus single camera which
is more like Aziz Ansari and the
marvelous missus Mazal master of none
then get those scripts read them see how
they introduce the characters see how
distinct all the voices are they're so
distinct and these will be some of your
best teachers
you